sitting at your desk looking at your
monitor during the day there's really
nothing out of the ordinary but if the
sun sets or I just cut the lights and
the room darkens you get this
characteristic glow from the monitor
contributing to that feeling of an
overwhelmingly bright light in the
darkness this is called a bloom effect
and at its heart it can be both a simple
and surprisingly complex effect to
implement do it right and it looks
subtle and sells that idea of an
overwhelmingly bright light but do it
wrong and the scene ends up looking a
bit wonky kinda straight out of the
mid-2000s let's talk about how it used
to be done way back in the day
there's really no official correct way
to do this whatever works but the
premise basically works like this you've
got a copy of your Mainframe buffer and
you'll apply some basic operations
you threshold the image meaning you
choose the bright parts to bloom out you
down sample it mostly for performance
reasons and you apply a bunch of blur to
it that's how you get that bleed over
effect
once you've done all that they can be
combined in some hand wavy way that
looks nice to end up with a bloomed out
image that's the theory anyway it's not
really set in stone this is kind of an
artistic effect so in reality you're
going to just go away whatever works and
looks nice
let's talk about thresholding and Image
First so what most people do is take the
image and do some sort of luminance cut
off the reasoning behind this was simple
a lot of stuff only ran with 8 bits per
Channel nowadays Modern Hardware is fast
enough to support floating Point buffers
wherever you need them but back in the
Dark Ages you often went with 8-bit
channels Xbox 360 had a 10 bit float
format but I don't think the PS3 had an
equivalent so yeah you take your image
and there's a bunch of ways people did
this you could contrast the heck out of
your image basically preserving the
bright areas and dropping off the rest
you can also set a luminous threshold so
calculated luminance per pixel and then
drop off towards zero everything below a
certain threshold
the general idea is that you need to
isolate some part of the image for
Blooming not all of it because we're
going to be additively blending this bad
board back onto the screen later
and without dropping off some parts
it'll look like a bit of a disaster you
can use the full size main color Target
directly but working with a smaller
version of that is faster and cheaper so
it's normal to take your main color
Target and down sample that to a
fraction of the size
every time you have your resolution the
number of pixels processed gets cut by a
75 percent which is pretty insane
savings
the trade-off here is that as you
progressively down sample you risk
shimmering artifacts due to the lack of
resolution
then there's a blur pass so you'll take
your main color which has probably been
down sampled and then you'll blur it
somehow
now a dead simple way is a good old box
blur nothing beats that
the basic idea is to convolve the image
with an equal weight kernel that might
look something like this
and that basically amounts to if you
were to zoom in and look at individual
pixels for any given pixel in the input
image you'd sample the nearby pixels and
then average them all together to
produce the final pixel in the output
image
go and do that a few zillion times for
every pixel in the image and you'll get
a slightly blurry image
this has some obvious limitations for
starters to get a bigger radius you can
either skip pixels which just kind of
looks bad
you can see the artifacts there pretty
clearly
or you can expand the kernel which looks
better but comes at the Steep cost of
being N squared for the radius you want
to blur bad options all around
luckily the Box filter is what's
referred to as a separable filter in
image processing
meaning that the 2D version can be
expressed as two one-dimensional filters
that is it can be done along the
horizontal axis or the x-axis
and then the output of that can be run
through another filter on the vertical
or y-axis
so I can start with the source image and
we can start by applying a box filter
along the x-axis
notice the blurring in the image is
strictly horizontal
once we've finished doing that we can
apply a second box filter along the
y-axis giving us the Box filter and two
end steps rather than N squared
in arguably higher quality blurs to do a
gaussian which is just changing the
weights around in the kernel instead of
equal weights you can bias the weight
towards the center pixel
the kernel basically looks like this
kind of a hill with a raised Center and
a gentle fall off towards the sides
contrast that to a box filter which is
exactly what it says it's a box
this is separable just like the Box blur
so it's easy to get going
there's other kernels here too but I
feel like the important takeaway here is
the general idea that you want to make a
blurry version of the scene
now that you've got your blurred out
copy of the scene you blend it back over
the screen as a post effect generally an
additive pass and that's it that's all
it is
problem is doing it this way is part of
the reason why the games in the
mid-2000s look so Bloom heavy they
relied on using things like thresholds
to bloom out if you've got an 8-bit per
Channel buffer that means that the
maximum value is 255. if you choose to
say use luminance the threshold what's
right and what isn't I.E what blooms and
what doesn't
that approach makes zero distinction
between just a white object and a
glowing hot one
the end result being it's super hard to
get under control
back in the day we developers thought it
looked awesome and so next-gen and it
kind of did so how about shut up
but let's look at how they've improved
the approach in some of the major
engines since those Bright bloomy Days
so in general any current generation
implementation of Bloom is going to be
trying to accomplish a few things
it's going to be high quality nuanced
we're long past the days where Bloom is
new and exciting so Bloom
implementations want to give that
feeling of an overwhelmingly bright
light without beating us over the head
with it
performant this should be obvious but it
should be fast
real fast
kawasi's blur filter
let's talk about new approaches but
before that way back at GDC 2003 this
was before I even started in the
industry there was a presentation by
misaki
kawasi kawasi I don't know it was a very
clever way to use GPU Hardware to get a
really nice blur for cheap the idea is
take the main image take four bilinear
samples and use those to downsample
progressively to a smaller resolution
in the talks I think they mentioned a
quarter resolution
after that you'll ping pong between two
textures each time taking four samples
at a time with an increasing offset by
iterating this over and over again you
can get a really good approximation to a
large gaussian blur for really few
texture samples
this is important because this algorithm
serves as the backbone for pretty much
all the modern approaches
let's start by taking a look at unity's
Bloom implementation in 2014 the folks
at Sledgehammer Games they were the ones
behind the latest at the time iteration
of Call of Duty so they outlined how
their Bloom implementation worked their
technique was an evolution of the Quasi
filter that we just outlined the idea is
as follows
you take your frame buffer and there's
no threshold step with HDR commonplace
now this isn't needed and you down
sample it to create basically a MIP
chain the default way is to take a
bilinear sample right in the middle of
every four texels and the Quasi method
showed us that you could take four taps
instead of one they decided screw it
we're taking 13 taps
and it's really neat what they do here
so if you're looking at this group of
pixels and we're going to take nine
samples total the upper left four will
form a group the upper right will form
another and so on lastly there'll be one
group of four samples in the middle and
that puts a large bias towards those
Center pixels the idea being that this
should help reduce pulsing artifacts
these are all combined with a single
equation with half the weight being the
center four and the rest of the four
groups getting equal weight
one extra trick they added here is that
on the very first down sample they take
the Keras average based on luminance
which helps preserve bright pixels
next they progressively upsample
starting with the smallest down sampled
image
each step they apply a tent filter to
the downsampled version and also some in
the previous MIP I think this is based
on the slides
so once you do that for a while you'll
end up with a fully done sample and then
re-up sampled image which you then lurp
with the main image to get a bloomed out
scene and overall it looks pretty good
notice that the scene isn't too bloomed
out liking shots from earlier in the
video the bloom is more subtle and comes
off more as a glow rather than a weird
Haze so unreal's approach seems to be
mostly an extension on those same older
techniques
they go over the general approach way
back in their siggraph 2012 presentation
on the technology behind the Unreal
Engine 4 Elemental demo from what I can
gather they take the main image the
frame buffer and from that they
progressively down sample a fixed number
of times using a plain kawasi blur
then they do a similar upscaling process
as Unity but from the sounds of it they
do a small separable gaussian blur at
each level which is artist configurable
so you can modify the size of the blur
at each level to your taste they also
add some knobs and dials for doing
things like applying tints to each level
giving you that extra level of artistic
control so I could for example
specifically choose to tint an
individual layer of the bloom chain
while leaving the rest as varying Shades
of Gray or something to that effect
I haven't tried profiling it my guess is
that it's slightly more expensive than
unity's approach but can give higher
quality and more flexible results
this is based on no actual research on
my part so while most of these
approaches are just tweaks and
evolutions on kawasi's approach from way
back the newer versions of Unreal Engine
come with a fancy new convolution Bloom
which is really interesting
if you have a signal let's represent it
with a seemingly random function here
then you can use something called the
Fourier transform to decompose that
function into a series of sinusoids a
series of sine and cosines of varying
amplitudes and frequencies
if you take an image and imagine each
pixel as data points of a 2d signal of a
two-dimensional function
then we can use a 2d transform to
convert this to frequency space and then
we can use the inverse Fourier transform
to bring this back to our original image
the whole Theory and background behind
the Fourier transform deserves a long
video by itself which I clearly didn't
do there are some phenomenal resources
on YouTube which I've got Linked In the
description
for our purposes I think it's probably
sufficient to know that this
transformation exists and what it buys
you in terms of functionality
once you've converted this to the
frequency domain there's some really
cool manipulations you can do
a high pass filter is one that preserves
high frequency information while
removing low frequency information
and that's as simple as multiplying by
zeroing out the image near the origin
before doing the inverse fft
a low pass filter is the exact opposite
preserving low frequency information
while discarding high which is the
inverse of what we just did and that
gives us a really blurry image
in fact I can actually perform a
gaussian blur in a similar Way by using
the Fourier transform of a gaussian
filter
which lets me perform a gaussian blur
for pretty much free
I mean free after the fft which wasn't
even slightly free
that kind of leads us to an interesting
property of the frequency domain
multiplying two images together in the
frequency domain is the equivalent to
convolving them in the time domain
this is where unreal's new convolution
Bloom is so neat and different you can
create custom Bloom kernel images
so here for example I can create a
star-like image which I've done just by
drawing some 2D sdfs
I've also added a bit of gaussian blurs
on top of that
now we can transform that kernel that I
just made into frequency Space by the
fft and multiply our four-year
transformed image
then when we take the inverse of that
using the inverse fft that ends up being
our blurry Bloom buffer when we combine
that with the frame buffer it gives us
this neat streaking effect that would be
a lot more difficult to do with
conventional methods but trivial using
this approach
the unfortunate downside is that doing
an fft is a heavy operation but I
imagine it's one that will probably see
more often as Graphics Hardware
undoubtedly gets more and more powerful
there was a time when doing Simple Loops
was unfathomable so a few more
iterations on hardware and this will be
a small blip on the profiler
until next time cheers